okay including the you reviewers movie
awards you got three videos coming from
me today I hope you guys don't get sick
of me
dried angry in 3d hell guns worked for
Doom all right so drive angry we've seen
the trailers we've heard about the test
screenings in comic-con that were
actually well received and the movie did
not look good but it did look fun and is
it no it's not good yeah it's actually
pretty fun first I'll talk about the 3d
this is the worst looking movie that was
actually shot in 3d 3d just hurt my eyes
I didn't like it but the movie is
exactly what it looks like it wasn't
good but if you like movies like Evil
Dead and machete you'll probably like
this one it's like the Mexican of
machete with white people in health so
like health sploit ation or white sploit
ation white people don't get
exploitation movies we just get grade-b
action movies a Nicholas Cage he's not a
great actor in this movie we've all seen
lately he's become a joke but as long as
he takes movies like kick ass and drive
angry it's almost like he's making fun
of the fact that he knows he's a joke so
it works now I'm being a grade B action
movie that you're not supposed to take
seriously
physics are negated in this movie which
simply means when a car gets hit it
flips up and over itself and off a
bridge every time cool to watch yes but
a part of your brain can't help but go
that doesn't happen on to the next good
thing the chick in the movie and the
chick is hot and that's that now on to
the best part of this movie William
Fichtner William Fichtner made this
movie you walk out of this movie you
talk and think about William Fichtner
he's like Satan's right-hand man hunting
Nicolas Cage down and he has this
absolute I do not give a [ __ ] attitude
like you know when you graduate high
school then you go back to visit for
some messed-up reason I don't know why
you would maybe you're visiting your old
teacher you like you're visiting a
classmate that's about to graduate or
you're scoping for chicks I don't know
whatever the reason when you walk into
that high school after you graduate
you're like wow the rules here just do
not apply to me and that's kind of how
William Fichtner is but the rules of the
world so it's just badass to see why
didn't know more about Nicolas Cage
though you find out about his story yeah
but you don't know much about him like
apparently like chicks are attracted to
him like he can glam them like Bill
Compton and [ __ ] our chicks attracted to
he'll things I don't know you don't know
so a fun movie some cool action awesome
supporting character William Fichtner
although I didn't think he was in it
enough the movie drags on a little bit
in the middle it's like a two-hour movie
it would have been a perfect 90-minute
movie so in the end this movie would be
a good time if you're drunk
yeah not stay in the movies bad I'm just
saying if you're hammered the experience
will probably be in
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more